VETERANS AFFAIRS WILL COME TO
ORDER. GOOD MORNING LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN AND TO OUR VETERANS
WHO HAVE SERVED OUR GREAT
COUNTRY IN THE ARMY NAVY AIR
FORCE MARINE CORPS COAST GUARD
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE. AND
IT WILL BEGIN THIS MORNING.
WITH SOME REMINDERS THAT IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC THE LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GALLERIES AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS TO THE PART OF
THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING ROOMS
TO THE EXTENT THE SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ARE
LOUD. AND WILL BE USING
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS. WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WHICH TO PER PUBLIC
COM. THE PARTICIPANT TOLD
NUMBER IS A FREE NUMBER AND THE
ACCESS CODE NUMBER TO BE POSTED
ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT
WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN
AND I WILL OF ANNOUNCER NOW.
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. TWO TWO SIX
EIGHT ONE FIVE TWO. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. THREE FIVE ONE
FOUR ONE NINE EIGHT FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES AND WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE
ENTER COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN
WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT WILL
BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO
DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION. PRESSES ONLY
ONE TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR
THE OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU TO A
LINE NUMBER. THIS CAN BE A
SHORT WAIT ONCE YOU RECEIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT
IN THE QUEUE. FOR THE MODERATOR
TO CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER AT
THAT TIME YOU WILL BE ON MUTED
AND YOU ARE NOW READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU MUST
MEET THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING
THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY IDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED. FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT IS BEING MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO
ARE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES.
PLAGIARIST BE RESPECTFUL BE
PATIENT. S. SO ALL THE
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD
WE THANK YOU. AND WE WILL BEGIN
THIS MORNING WITH THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. FOR WE CONTINUE
TODAY'S AGENDA LET'S ESTABLISH
A QUORUM. I'D LIKE TO REMIND
THE MEMBERS TO TURN ON THEIR
MICROPHONES AND CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FOR THE-
MARCH- ACTUAL ADDRESS GROW HERE.
HERE GROW HERE EGGMAN HERE
EGGMAN HERE MELENDEZ. HERE
MELENDEZ HERE NEWMAN. NEWMAN
HERE ROTH HERE BROUGHT HERE
NUMBER. NUMBER HERE. THE
CONSULTANT NOTES WE HAVE A
QUORUM AND A QUORUM HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED WE HAVE FOUR BILLS
ON THE CALENDAR TODAY TO OUR ON
CONSENT DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. SENATOR
BURKE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
MOTION ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
AGAIN PLEASE TURN YOUR
MICROPHONE JOHN SO WE CAN HEAR
YOUR VOTE. CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR PARTULA HI ARCHULETA
HIGH GROWTH HIGH GROWTH HI
EGGMAN. SEGMENT HI MELENDEZ HI
MELENDEZ HI NEWMAN. NEWMAN HI
ROB. ROTH HI NUMBER HI NUMBER
HI. THE CONSENT THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS OUT SEVEN I IS NO.
AND WE WILL BEGIN THIS MORE
MORNING WITH SENATE BILL THREE
EIGHT CENTER GROVE GOOD MORNING
CENTER GROVE YOU MAY PROCEED IF
YOU WERE READY ABSOLUTELY SIR
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN BERS SB
THREE FORTY EIGHT WILL REQUIRE
CALVET PRIOR TO CLOSING THE
CALIFORNIA VETERANS HOME TO
ESTABLISH A TASK FORCE MADE UP
OF REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
DEPARTMENT. AND FROM FROM THE
DEPARTMENT ELECTED OFFICIALS
AND COMMUNITY RESIDENTS AND
STAFF FROM THE HOME AS WELL AS
LOCAL VETERANS GROUPS THIS TASK
FORCE WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
SUBMIT RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON THE HOME AND
PROVIDE A REVIEW OF COMMUNITY
INPUT INCLUDING EFFORTS TO
ENCOURAGE PARTICIPATION IN
COMMUNITY MEETINGS RELATED TO
THE PROPOSED HOME CLOSURE LAST
YEAR THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED A
BUDGET THAT REDUCED FUNDING FOR
THE BARSTOW VETERANS HOME SO
SIGNIFICANTLY THAT THE ONLY
OPTION GOING FORWARD WAS A FULL
CLOSURE. THE LIMITED OPTIONS
FOR ALTERNATIVE PLACEMENT IN
THE IDEA OF LEAVING THEIR HOMES
COMBINED WITH THE LACK OF
COMMUNICATION FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION CAUSE
SIGNIFICANT DISTRESS FOR THESE
VETERANS IN THESE IN THIS HOME
BUT LIVE IN BARSTOW IN ADDITION
THE EMPLOYMENT DECLINED THE
EMPLOYMENT OF THE DEDICATED
HARD WORKING STAFF WAS PUT IN
JEOPARDY. WE QUICKLY DISCOVERED
THAT THE PROCESS THAT TOOK
PLACE IN THE PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION ON THIS PROPOSAL
WAS VERY LIMITED RESIDENTS AND
STAFF AND COMMUNITY MEMBERS
FELT APART FROM CALLING MY
OFFICE THEY COULD NOT
MEANINGFULLY VOICE DIRECT
CONCERNS REGARDING THIS
PROPOSED CLOSURE OF THIS
VETERANS HOME. UNLIKE THE
PROCESS OF CLOSING A
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER WHICH
INCLUDES REGULAR BRIEFINGS AND
LEGISLATIVE STAFF. REQUIREMENTS
FOR A PUBLIC HEARING. AND THIS
SALUTE INPUT FROM A BROAD RANGE
OF. IN RESIDENTS THERE WAS NO
SO PROCESS IN PLACE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR THE
CLOSURE OF ONE OF ITS VETERANS
HOMES SB THREE FORTY EIGHT
REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT TO
ESTABLISH A TASK FORCE TO
CONSIDER ALL THE IMPLEMENTS
IMPLICATIONS. OF THE PROPOSED
CLOSURE TO INCLUDE- IN THE
PUBLIC PROCESS. IN THIS BILL IS
SUPPORTED BY VARIOUS VETERANS
GROUPS INCLUDING AMVETS
DEPARTMENT OF CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTY VETERANS SERVICES
OFFICERS. CALIFORNIA STATE
COMMANDERS VETERANS COUNCIL
JOINING ME TODAY ON THE PHONE
AS A KEY WITNESS IS SAMPOERNA
DINO COUNTY SUPERVISOR DAN OUR
SKIS ME DON ROUTE- DISTRICT.
SUPERVISOR AND SET THREE
VETERAN HIMSELF TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU
SENATOR WILL NOW MOVE TO ANYONE
WANTED TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
DUE TO CONSTRAINTS REGARDING
THE LENGTH OF THE HEARING
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS AND
CLEANING PROP PORTER CALLED
COMMITTEE CHAIR MANAGE TO TOOT
TIME LIMITS ON TESTIMONY EACH
SIDE WILL HAVE THREE MINUTES.
ALL OTHERS TO TEST MUSCLE THEIR
TO THEY'RE CA. TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION POSITION ON THE
MEASURE. MODERATOR PLEASE
RELEASE THE LINE FOR THE LEAD
SUPPORT WITNESSES WILL BEGIN
WITH DON ROLE SAMBAR DINO
COUNTY SUPERVISOR THIRD
DISTRICT FOLLOWED BY SETH REED
FROM REED GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
AND- DON ROWE YOU MAY BEGIN.
GOOD MORNING MISTER TURNER
THANK YOU FOR THE ACT. JESSICA
THIS IS MY FOR TIME DEMANDING A
BRIEF FOR IT'LL TAKE ME ABOUT
BECAUSE- PLEASE GO RIGHT AHEAD.
THANK YOU SIR I WANT TO START
BY THANKING EACH OF YOU FOR
YOUR COMMITMENT TO OUR COUNTRY
IN THE PAST THE VETERAN I
SERVED AS THE THIRD DISTRICT
SUPERVISOR FOR SAMPOERNA DINO
COUNTY IN MY DISTRICT DOES
INCLUDE THE CITY OF BARSTOW THE
VETERANS HOME THE SUBJECT IS
ESPECIALLY TO ME AS I AM GOLD
STAR WIFE. HAS WAS A MARINE
CORPS KILLED IN A ROW IN TWO
AND I HAVE LIVED THE IN THAT
THE RAVAGES THE RAP OF WAR HAVE
ON OUR SERVICE AND THEIR- LAST
YEAR I WAS APPALLED LEARN THE
PRINTER CLOSURE OF THE VOTERS
THAT YOU HOME. AS A MATTER OF
SELLING SOLVING THE STATE DEATH
WAS BEING USED CLOTHING
HOMEWARE HAVE TO NEAR TWO
VETERAN AND RICK MOST IF NOT TO
RE TO OTHER BACK HOME THIS. YOU
CAN THERE WAS IMMEDIATE
OUTPOURING ABOUT THE FROM
DEGREE YOU NEED MEMBERS AND
LOCAL ELECTED LIKE MY. I TO
DISCOVER THE THERE ISN'T A MORE
FOR PROCESS FOR TO. THAT BY.
CLOSURES WEIGH IN. VETERANS ARE
IN INTEGRAL OF OUR TEAM. THAT
THEY SERVE. AND IT CLEAR TO
THERE WAS A NEED TO BE MORE TO.
IN THE CAR. OF AMPLE UP. FOR
AND- I COMMEND SENATOR GROW FOR
INTER. SB TWO FORTY. THE
MEASURE AS- THE- PARKS. PROCESS
FOR ANY PER. THAT HOME BECAUSE-
AND GET THE STRONG VOICE THAT
ACTION AT RISK OF LOSING. A
BENEFIT THAT THERE RIGHTLY HAVE
OR ON ABOUT. I APPRECIATE YOUR-
YOU CAN. OF SENATE BILL THREE
FOUR EIGHT AND I RESPECT
REQUEST SUPPORT ON THE MEASURE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND NOW
WE WILL HEAR FROM. THREE WHO IS-
ON THE LINE. GOOD MORNING CHAIR
MEMBER MY NAME IS SET THREE
BROWN AND THAT DEPARTMENT CAL
CALIFORNIA STATE VETERANS K. IN
THE CALIFORNIA. ASSOCIATION
COUNTY BY SERVICE OFFICER. IT'S
HOMES PROVIDE RATHER AND STILL
NO SERVICES FOR VETS AND THE
SPOUSES THE OF AND ALLEGE.
RECOGNIZED AND AGAIN THE NEED
PROVIDE THE SIR. AND GREAT F.
AND EXPERTS. WAS EXPANDED TO
BILL AND STAFF THE HOME.
VETERANS JUNE LEADERS ACTIVISTS
THE P. FROM ACROSS STATE ARE TO
GET THESE HOW OF PER. THERE CAN
BE NO ADVANTAGE TO CALL TO
WITHOUT THE OF THE VECTOR
COMMUNITY. AND STATE. THE TOWN.
AND SUPPORT SB THREE FORTY
EIGHT AND WE WERE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS
BILL. THANK YOU AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SERVICE- WILL NOW MOVE
TO ANY WITNESSES HERE IN THE
SENATE CHAMBERS. ARE THE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM. ONE TWELVE.
I SEE NONE- THANK YOU FOR THE
WITNESSES- IF NOT WE'LL GO TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELEPHONE MODERATOR
PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SENATE BILL THREE FORTY
EIGHT. AND WE WILL BEGIN. THANK
YOU AND IF YOU'RE SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL THREE
FORTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH TONE
PHONE AT THIS TIME. YOU HEAR AN
INDICATION YOU'VE BEEN PLACED
INTO THE QUEUE AND YOU MAY
REFER TO AN EIGHTEEN T.
SPECIALIST. WILL PROVIDE YOU
WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER. YOU MAY
REMOVE YOURSELF FROM THE QUEUE
BY REPEATING THE ONE THEN ZERO
COMMAND. IF YOU'RE USING A
SPEAKER. PLEASE PICK UP YOUR
HANDSET BEFORE PRESSING ANY
BUTTONS AND MAKE SURE YOUR
PHONE IS ON MUTE. MODERATE I
MEAN WE DON'T TO FIND. FIVE NO
ONE QUEUING AT THIS TO. THANK
YOU- ONE TIME LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE ELSE ON THE LINE
PLEASE. ONCE AGAIN IF THERE IS
ANYONE SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER
CHAIRMAN WE HAVE KNOWN UP GOOD.
I HAVEN'T HEARD FROM THE LEAD
SUPPORTER- THERE ANYWAY. HERE
THE TO WISH TO TESTIFY IN OP. I
SEE NO ONE ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WISH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
OF SENATE BILL. THREE FORTY
EIGHT. I SEE NONE THANK YOU
KNOW A MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
TELEPHONE. MODERATOR PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SENATE
BILL. THREE FORTY EIGHT. AND
AGAIN IF YOU'RE TESTIFYING IN
OPPOSITION SENATE BILL THREE
FORTY EIGHT PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. MODERATOR THERE
OR ANYONE- ELSE WAITING DO YOU
HAVE ANYONE ELSE HELLO WE HAVE
NO ACUTE MR SURE. MONTEREY
PLEASE CHECK MORE TIME
UNSCENTED THREE FORTY EIGHT IN
OPPOSITION. AND AGAIN IF
THERE'S ANY OPPOSITION TO
SENATE BILL THREE FORTY EIGHT
PLEASE TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. THANK WE ADDED ON QUEUING
UP SIR CAN. YOU HAVE ONE. NO
THANK YOU- FOR YOUR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION THE WITNESSES AND
NOW WILL BRING THE DISCUSSION
BACK TO THE MEMBERS MEMBERS.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SENATOR
MELENDEZ THANK THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN- I JUST WANT TO THANK
SENATOR GRAHAM FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD IN BEING SO
TENACIOUS ABOUT MAKING SURE
THAT OUR VETERANS- ARE INDEED
TAKING CARE OF AND HAVE A PLACE
TO GO IF THEY NEED TO GIVEN THE
FACT THAT THIS STATE HAS- THIS
YEAR I THINK ABOUT FIFTEEN
BILLION AND A SURPLUS I THINK
WE CAN CERTAINLY AFFORD TO FUND
ON THESE HOMES THAT ARE
VETERANS SO DESPERATELY NEED SO
WITH THAT I'M I WOULD LIKE TO
MOVE THE BILL INAPPROPRIATE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. THANK
YOU CENTER GROVE WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
ALL OF US IS VETERANS ON THIS
FLOOR- UNDERSTAND THE UNIQUE
EXPERIENCE OF RAISING RIGHT
HAND SWEARING TO DEFEND THE
CONSTITUTION AGAINST ALL
ENEMIES FOREIGN AND DOMESTIC
VETERANS IN CALIFORNIA
ESPECIALLY VETERANS AND OUR
VETERANS HOME AND SHOULD HAVE
AT MINIMUM A DUE PROCESS AND
HAVE INPUT IN THE CLOSURE OF
THESE HOMES WHICH THEY HAVE NOT
HAD A NET IN THE PAST AND SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU AND SAID
MELINDA- FOR MOVE THE BILL YOU
SO. IN NOW WE GO ON TO THE CA.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE MOST
IS TO PAY BUT FOR ROOF TO A PRO.
ARCHULETA BY ARCHULETA HI
GROWTH I. GREW HI EGGMAN FIVE
EGGMAN HI MY- I. MELENDEZ AYE
NEWMAN. NEW NAY ROTH LIKE RON
HI NUMBER HI I'M HI. THE BILL
IS OUT- SO ZERO YOU SO CENTER.
AND NOW WILL MOVE ON TO SENATE
BILL SIX SIX FIVE NUMBER GOOD
MORNING TO YOU AND ARE YOU
READY TO PROCEED WITH YOUR
SENATE BILL SIX SIX FIVE I AM
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IS
READY. THANK YOU MR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- SB SIX SIX FIVE IS
VERY SIMPLE BILL IT SIMPLY FOR
THE PRIVATE SECTOR EMPLOYERS
THE SAME OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
A PREFERENCE FOR VETERANS THAT
EXISTS IN THE PUBLIC SECTOR
BOTH STATE AND FEDERAL
GOVERNMENTS PROVIDE PREFERENCES
FOR VETERANS- THIS IS A LONG
OVERDUE. PROVISION THAT ALLOWS
PRIVATE EMPLOYERS TO DO THE
SAME THING THERE AT THREE
PURPOSES ONE IS TO RECOGNIZE
THE SERVICE AND SACRIFICE OF
SERVICE MEMBERS TO IS TO ACT
ACTUALLY ISN'T AN INDUCEMENT
FOR INDIVIDUALS TO JOIN THE
MILITARY AND THREE IT ALLOWS
THE PRIVATE SECTOR THE SAME
OPPORTUNITY AS THE PUBLIC
SECTOR TO HIRE VETERANS WHAT
WHICH I THINK. IT VETERANS ARE
A VERY VALUABLE RESOURCE BOTH
OF THE PUBLIC AS WELL AS
PRIVATE SECTOR- GINGIVAL WITH
ME- TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
MISTER MICHAEL COLE A
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL OF
S. H. R. M. AS WELL AS ARI
FRIEDMAN POFESSIONAL TREATMENT.
COORDINATOR OF DISNEY PARKS.
THANK YOU SENATOR WILL MOVE NOW
ON TO- ANYWAY WOULD LIKE TO
TEST. IN SO. ALL RIGHT AGAIN
IT'S WILL PREPARE WILL BE PER
THREE MINUTES AND YOUR PRIMARY
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION ALL
OTHER TUITION TO TESTIFY MUST
LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR
NAME AFFILIATION POSITION ON
THE MEASURE. MODERATOR PLEASE
RELEASE THE LINE UP FOR THE
LEAD SUPPORT WITNESS MICHAEL
CALLED GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
DIRECTOR CALIFORNIA STATE
COUNCIL OF SOCIETY FOR HUMAN
RESOURCES MANAGEMENT FOLLOWED
BY OUR EAP FRIEDMAN
PROFESSIONAL RECRUITMENT
COORDINATOR DISNEY PARKS AND HE
WILL PROCEED WITH MICHAEL-
CALLED PLEASE GO AHEAD MICHAEL.
HI GOOD MORNING CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
WE CAN DO THAT HERE ARE KILLED
HERE TO LET IN MEMBERS MY NAME
IS MICHAEL CALLED APPEARING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
SOCIETY FOR HUMAN RESOURCE
MANAGEMENT AND ITS AFFILIATES
THE SOCIETY FOR HUMAN RESOURCE
MANAGEMENT. WE ARE PROUD TO
SUPPORT AND SPONSOR SB SIX SIX
FIVE EVERYBODY WANTS TO THANK
VETERANS FOR THEIR SERVICE SB
SIX SIX FIVE GOES BEYOND THE
VERBAL THANK YOU AND ONE
MATERIAL THE VETERANS AND
FINDING GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT.
WHICH IS CRUCIAL TO VETERANS
LONG TERM ECONOMIC AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL BENEFITS MANY
EMPLOYERS WANT TO ACTIVELY
RECRUIT AND HIRE VETERANS BUT
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE CIVIL
LAWSUIT ACCORDINGLY SB SIX SIX
FIVE WOULD ALLOW EMPLOYERS TO
PROVIDE A VOLUNTARY HIRING
PREFERENCE PROVIDED THEY IT
HERE SB SIX SIX FIVE
REQUIREMENTS. TO ENSURE DOES
NOT. USE AND IMPROPER MANNER.
THIRTY VOLUNTEER HIRING FOR.
ENTIRELY LAW. OVER FORTY STATE
RED BLUE AND PURPLE HAVE
ENACTED SUCH PREFERENCES.
ALWAYS OVERWHELMINGLY AND OFTEN
UNANIMOUSLY. IS ALSO CONSIDERED
TO A CALIFORNIA LAW WHICH
ALLOWED HIRING PREFERENCES. IN
THE PUBLIC SECTOR INDEED
CALIFORNIA ALREADY HAS A
PREFERENCE PROVISION FOR
PRIVATE EMPLOYERS SB SIX SIX
FIVE SIMPLY MODERNIZE.
MODERNIZE THIS PREFERENCE TO BE
USED FOR VETERANS WHO SERVED
AFTER THE VIETNAM WAR. IT ALSO
FAIR VETERANS BRING UNIQUE
SKILL SETS THAT RENDER THEM
QUALIFIED FOR THE POSITION THAT
THEY SEEK EVEN IF THE RESUMES
PERHAPS LOOK DIFFERENT THAN
THOSE WHO TOOK A MORE
TRADITIONAL ROUTE. TO THE
EXTENT THERE IS A TIE BETWEEN
CANDIDATES IT IS NOT AN FAIR
IN FAVOR THOSE WHO ELECTED TO
SERVE. AND DELAY THEIR PRIVATE
EMPLOYMENT CAREERS. LASTLY IT
IS NOT DISCRIMINATORY SB SIX
SIX FIVE INCLUDES NUMEROUS
PREVIOUSLY PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
TO ENSURE COULD NOT BE USED TO
INTENTIONALLY DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST ANY PROTECTED GROUP. SB
SIX SIX FIVE OPPONENTS
EXPRESSED CONCERN ABOUT A
POTENTIAL DISCRIMINATORY
IMPACT. RESPECTFULLY THERE'S NO
EVIDENCE THAT IN THE FORTY
STATE WHO RECENTLY USED SUCH
PREFERENCES. MOREOVER SUCH AN
UNFAIR IMPACT IS UNLIKELY SINCE
THE CURRENT MILITARY IS
INCREDIBLY DIVERSE OFTEN WITH
MEMBERS OF PROTECTED GROUPS
UNLISTED AT HIGHER RATES THAN
THE GENERAL POPULATION. WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT THE
COMMITTEE SUPPORT SB SIX SIX
FIVE WITH AN AYE VOTE. I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE AND I'LL NOW TURN.
IT OVER TO ARI FRIEDMAN THANK
YOU. THANK GOODNESS GOING TO
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR- I AM
ARE FRIEDMAN TOOK SERVE ACTION
THE READER JUST RETURN HOME
DEPLOYMENT MONTH I ALSO WORK IN
TOWN WITH THE DEVELOP BETTER. I
AND FAVOR THIS BILL THE U. S.
IN THE SYMBOL DIVERSE A PLAYER
NOT ONLY ARE WE SUPPORT BETTER.
BUT ALSO THEIR FIRST EQUITY ON.
FOR VETERANS AND HIRING. FOR
EXAMPLE MY CURRENT EMPLOYER THE
WORLD COME. AND RELATED CAPTAIN
MOVIE. ALSO BECAUSE THAT MOVIES
EFFORTS TO INCREASE WITH TYLER.
BEING ELECTED THE U. S. AIR AND
NAVY TO. THIS BILL WILL BE
GREAT FOR US AND PEOPLE LIKE WE
HAVE A TEAM OPPORTUNITY AS WE
DO IN PUBLIC SECTOR AS WELL THE
PRIVATE. ONE TWELVE ONE ONE
TWO. I SEE NONE- THANK YOU FOR
OF THE WITNESSES TESTIFYING SO
NOW LET'S MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
VIA THE TELEPHONE MODERATOR
PLEASE PROP INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL SIX SIX AT SIX SIX FIVE
AND WE WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU IF
YOU'RE SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL SIX SIX FIVE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH
TONE PHONE. THE SPECIALIST WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER THAT WILL OPEN YOUR LINE
WHEN YOU'RE WHEN YOU'RE CALLED
UPON. I WILL FIRST GO TO LINE
NINETEEN. BY NINETEEN YEAR OPEN
GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS
ALEX OR THE DREADED YOU THREE
SIXTY ON THE HAVE BEEN
CALIFORNIA OF BETTER SERVICE
AGENCIES APOLOGIES WE GOT OUR
LETTER IN LATE THE ONE AND IT
CARE SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE'LL GO NEXT TO LINE SEVENTEEN.
GOOD MORNING RICHARD MEMBERS
REFUSED KEVIN BAKER TO DINNER
CONSIDER PRODUCING AND I THINK
I MAY BE OUT OF ORDER IN THE
QUEUE UNFORTUNATELY BUT- WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY- STILL IN
OPPOSITION BECAUSE OF THE-
UNFORTUNATE DISPARATE IMPACT OF
THE PROPOSAL DESPITE THE-
DIVERSITY OF THE ARMED FORCES.
IT IS STILL NOT REPRESENTATIVE
OF THE CHAMBER WORKFORCE AND
JOKE IT IS A POTENTIAL ARE
DISCRIMINATORY IMPACT ON
MILLION PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES MEMBERS OF THE
LGBT COMMUNITY LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE ALTAR. TO
ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS THANK YOU.
WE'LL GO TO LINE TWENTY GO
AHEAD. MY TWENTY YEAR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRS-
THE MORNING CARE NUMBER SINCE
SEPT REPORT TO GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS FOR I CANNOT LIKE TO
THANK ALLTHE MEMBERS FOR THEIR
SERVICE- AND I SERVED IN THE U.
S. ARMY AS AN INFANTRYMAN FROM
TO THOUSAND FOUR TO. TWO
THOUSAND NINE. I'M HERE TODAY
REPRESENTING AMERICAN LEGION
DEPARTMENT CALIFORNIA EMBEDS
CALIFORNIA. JERRY OBSOLETE
EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA
PROPOSAL CHARACTERS ALL IN
SUPPORT OF THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THANK YOU. THE.
GOING TO LINE SIXTEEN OKAY
PLACE. WHY CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME MADE AND
I READ THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE IN SUPPORT OF AT THE
SIX SIX FIVE THANK YOU. IF
THERE ARE ANY. OTHER SPEAKERS
IN SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL SIX
SIX FIVE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. RICHER WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN Q. YOU MAY PROCEED
OKAY THANK YOU. HAVE YOU HEARD
FROM SUPPORTERS AND- WITNESSES
HERE IN THE CHAMBER AND- SO NOW
WILL GO HEAD AND GO ON TO
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE HERE
IN THE CHAMBER- WISHES TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. I SEE NONE OTHER
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE ONE TWO
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION THE SENATE BILL SIX
SIX FIVE. I SEE NONE THANK YOU
WILL MOVE ON THE WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
TELEPHONE. MODERATORPLEASE
STAND YOUR INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
SENATE BILL SIX SIX FIVE. THANK
YOU IF OU'RE SPEAKINGIN
OPPOSITION OF SENATE BILL SIX
SIX FIVE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE AT THIS
TIME. MODERATOR HOW MANY ARE
WAITING IN THE QUEUE. WE HAVE
KNOWN CUED UP SIR. SOMEONE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
PLEASE OPEN THE LINE FOR ANYONE.
GIVEN THAT OPPORTUNITY. OKAY IF
ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK ON
THIS PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AGAIN PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE
HAVE NO IN QUEUING UP AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU- THANK YOU ALL
FOR THOSE WHOSE WHO SPOKE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILLS WILL NOW
OR OPPOSITION WILL NOW BRING
THE DISCUSSION BACK TO THE
MEMBERS. MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS- TO THE BILL
SENATOR NEWMAN THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND- A REMINDER TURN ON
YOUR MICROPHONE. OR DID YOU
HAVE A COMMENT. TO MOVE THE
BILL THAT HE SO AGGRESSIVELY
OFFERED I ACTUALLY WANT TO
COMMEND SENATOR UMBERG. ON THIS
BILL- DIED PRIOR TO SERVING AYE
I WORKED FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS
AND THEIR EMPLOYMENT- IN OUR
REGION- AND THE ABSENCE OF A
VETERAN'S PREFERENCE HAD A
MATERIAL IMPACT ON VETERANS
PROSPECTS AND SO. GLAD THAT YOU
BROUGHT THIS BILL AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK YET IS A CO
AUTHOR OF THIS OPPORTUNITY. TO
DO THAT AS IT MOVES FORWARD
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
NEWMAN AND THANKS FOR MOVING
THE BILL- CONSULTED ANY CLOSING
REMARKS CENTER NUMBER. OH I'M
SORRY OVER HERE TO THE RIGHT
CENTER GROVE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS THANK YOU MISTER TERRY
TO WOULD LIKE TO- A
COMMENCEMENT OR AND BIRD FOR
THIS BILL- YOU KNOW IN THE IN
THE REAL WORLD I WANT TO
BUSINESS IT PUTS- INDIVIDUALS
OUT TO WORK AND- AND- IT WAS
THIS WILL BE A GREAT BENEFIT TO
ANY BUSINESS HE WANTS TO HIRE
INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE SERVED
OUR COUNTRY. THE UNITED STATES
MILITARY VETERANS THAT HAVE
TRANSFERABLE SKILLS- WHICH
ALWAYS TRANSLATE INTO THE
PRIVATE SECTOR AND SO THANK YOU
SIR VRY MUCH FOR INTRODUCING
THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION IT IT
TRULY WILL BENEFIT VETERANS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU CENTER GROVE'S CENTER AMBER
WOULD YOU WISH TO. HAVE CLOSING
COMMENTS. THANK YOU FOR THOSE
COMMENTS SURGEON IVEL. VERY
GOOD THANK YOU CONSULTANT CALL
THE ROLL.
ONCE AGAIN THE BILL
WAS MOVED BY SENATOR NEWMAN I
BELIEVE IT WAS AT CENTER GROVE.
CENTER ROTH THERE YOU ARE DOWN
THERE CENTER ROTH THANK YOU
AND- NOW WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
CALL THE ROLL. COULD SEE DOWN
THERE. THE MOTION IS DO YOU
PASS THAT FIRST RE REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS ARCHULETA BY
PARTULA I'D GROWTH I. GREW HI
EGGMAN. EGGMAN AYE MELENDEZ AYE
MELENDEZ AYE NEWMAN NEWMAN AYE
ROTH ROTH HI NUMBER NUMBER I.
THE BILL IS OUT SEVEN HI ZERO
NO AND- FOR NOW I'D LIKE TO
THANK EVERYONE FOR THEIR
ATTENDANCE AND THANK YOU ALL
THE STAFF AND TO PUT THIS YEAR
TOGETHER AND EVERYONE WHO
SUBMITTED THEIR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION- IF YOU WERE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
COMMITTEE ON MILITARY VETERANS
AFFAIRS OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE.
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT
TO INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN
THE OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD
THANK YOU EVERYONE FOR
PARTICIPATING AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE- WE HAVE
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA OF THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON MILITARY
AND VETERANS AFFAIRS. IS HEREBY
ADJOURNED.